I do remember getting a phone call one
morning at 4:00 a.m. from the production
manager who said don't bother to come to
work today and I said why am i fired and
he said no but the set has just burned
to the ground it was four o'clock in the
morning and the night watchman saw smoke
coming out the door of the soundstage
and interestingly it was while we were
shooting the exorcism scene and the
place was refrigerated overnight we had
three large refrigeration units that
would refrigerate the peninsula hotel
they were so powerful and so that when
we would come in in the morning the set
would be about 30 below zero every
morning and Linda Blair wore that
nightgown with just some long underwear
that you couldn't see the rest of us
were all dressed as though we were on a
ski slope we were all in heavy winter
gear and the minute the lights went on
the temperatures started to rise but
with those air conditioning units one
day the set caught fire and burned to
the ground the sets were separate the
house was a separate set from the
bedroom but they were in the same
building and the set involving the house
burned and the insurance company paid
off because we had a shutdown we shut
down for six weeks it was that long to
rebuild the we had to rebuild the entire
set and the insurance company paid off
on the basis that because it was an old
building though and there were pigeons
flying around
the rafters a pigeon flew into a light
box causing a short-circuit
and thus the fire that's the only thing
that happened during the entire film
that I thought was some kind of bad
karma I will say one other thing I
thought was strange
we made the Statue of Pazuzu in Burbank
in the workshop at the Burbank Studios
it was 15 feet tall and with the wing
spread it was about 8 feet wide and it
was put into a box and shipped by a very
famous group of X fighter pilots that
became that started a shipping company
after the World War two the Flying
Tigers and we had this statue of Pazuzu
addressed to Warner Brothers care of the
bath as party in Mosul Iraq and somehow
or other it got to Denmark it went to
some it was lost we couldn't start
shooting in Iraq for three or four weeks
waiting for this statue which went
somewhere else by the Flying Tigers and
I don't know how the hell that happened
finally it got to us but that is
probably the only other thing I think
was strange